assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to buffers assisting their friends
hope you guys are doing well if there's
none was in tune and into this which I'm
sure they will be it's great that you've
come to my channel inshallah because our
whole point today is obviously you guys
know from the title there's room in
Ganga Sharia and as Muslims we would
love for you guys to hear where we're
coming from and we just really
appreciate it for a moment
we know the news everyone Muslim Muslim
Muslim we just want you to today zone
out meaning put that thinking to a side
and hear us out what does is stand
really teach and as Muslims
what is our safe on this metal of women
young girls whoever it may be whoever
it's done by how do you feel
automatically as a human being yeah not
talking about religion or race or
caustic read immediately when you hear
stuff like this it sickens you to the
core yes it's a vile and cowardly act to
be preying on disenfranchised and
vulnerable children women or anyone yes
who's been a victim to this that's the
first and foremost and that's what we
want to make clear as well from the
beginning this video is by no means in
any fraction of the matter that we are
defending it yet this act has absolutely
no defense whatsoever and any human
being that has you know any emotion or
justice in their heart will see
something like this and they will
automatically be disgusted to the core
exactly if there's one thing with
defending were just trying to defend
Islam from this vile exactly that is
only one so when we strong is free from
so when we come with statistics and
stuff like that the only concern with
defending here is were freeing Islam
from these individuals that's the only
thing and when you said that it reminded
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
when a man came and said I want to
commit sexual intercourse with this yeah
and the Prophet sat him down and this is
imagine it says sexual intercourse
meaning two people are concerned
consenting let alone not consenting and
taking them and exploiting them here the
Prophet Muhammad missile from he said
would you want that for your mom
he said no I wouldn't would you
wonderful daughter for your sister the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
you wouldn't want that for your own yeah
then one and this is two people
consenting so let alone somebody go in
and say no I'm gonna how would
the kid as well because this is an issue
and it is happening in certain
communities it's very important that if
you are a Muslim or you're embroiled or
you're around this is a few things to
understand there because one issue that
people did say was certain communities
want to keep such issues hidden yeah we
can't go away from this night and it's
very important Islamically you shouldn't
keep it hidden yeah in fact there's a
very good verse that comes to mind
chapter chapter 4 verse 135 o you who
believe be upholders of justice
witnesses for Allah even if it goes
against yourselves your parents or your
family so if you are a parent and your
child is embroiled in some madness it is
your duty to make sure they are brought
to justice
yeah you don't take them to the side and
say no don't worry we'll discover up or
whatnot this has to be brought out and
just because someone is white black or
brown or whatever Islam is the only
religion that overtly clearly in text
refutes racism clearly yeah clearly
so these perpetrators that are targeting
white so or whatever this is against the
Islamic principle of there's no
connection there is no way you Familia
connect with Islam is antithetical let's
watch a video which you're gonna react
to hopefully let's watch that and then
we're gonna come sister su that they're
simply hard to believe but this one is
true as many as 1 million white English
children may have been the victims of
Muslim rape gangs better known as
grooming gangs in towns up and down
Great Britain policy analyst Jorge
Ziggler I mean when you counter an issue
that is just so unbelievable just so
outside your frame of reference and
understanding the immediate human
reaction is just not want to believe it
at all perhaps even harder to believe is
that while there have been prosecutions
British authorities have still not
stopped this criminal activity there's a
particular problem involving Pakistani
heritage men who target young vulnerable
white English girls not my words but a
member of parliament Jack Straw who also
these Pakistani heritage men the white
English girls as quote easy meat this is
when some shout racism but here are the
facts calculations based on convictions
show that a British Muslim male is 170
times more likely to be part of a sex
grooming gang than a non-muslim and
there are no recorded instances of
non-muslims do Leske by my current
witness to Muslim girls is part of a
criminal enterprise in one local
jurisdiction it was estimated that six
out of seven Muslim males either knew
about or were part of a grooming gang
what you do not have is any example of
non Muslim men targeting Muslim girls
for this organized form of abuse so the
argument says this crime exists
everywhere is not only false but is
being deliberately cultivated by the
media and by the government inquiry that
is kicking the can down the rows the
grooming game ok let's stop there yeah
so I heard
keywords yeah he started off with Muslim
instantly then it was Pakistani then I
heard easy meat meaning that these
individuals are talking because these
girls are easy and what this guide is
said and Oh hundred and where as Muslims
we are aren't we we a hundred and
seventy times more likely to do this
which is I don't know what statistics
that's crazy I don't know maybe I don't
know where he got that for me I don't
maybe the new maths at school is their
Caucasian grooming guns of course
they're wrong okay okay let's what's the
percentage the rest this is a fringe
this is a branch that's been taken of
the umbrella you were talking about was
my sex abuse this grooming gangs is one
lol of them you can look at fifty
thousand people are watching indecent
child pictures online
you've got currently 261 celebrities
that are being well investigated for
child sex abuse you're seeing Scotland
Yard covering this up yeah okay this
okay alright so thirty
Senko k jr. and the recitation you
cannot resolution those 22% black 20
impersonation okay it is what's in
common
the victims are all the time you see the
victims of white okay so then we need to
ask a question why are the Caucasian and
the black men going for white girls yes
it could be could be a little race it
could be no no what no no even a
Caucasian why are they going for the one
no no what is the question because it
feels the victims seems like it's a
regular pattern of victims the
perpetrators are a mixture so if the
perpetrators are a mixture and the
victim is the same how can you get a
small group and say look victims are the
same look these guys do G I'm trying to
see ya because the thing is is it shows
it comes back to easy meet yeah easy
meet not for the only for the Asian
grooming guns viral and mousse but the
same with the perpetrators black and
what they're doing the same thing okay
what do we blame them okay okay why does
the copy only that's the only reason why
they doing right-wingers aren't as vocal
about other races or cultures or
religions as they are about Muslims okay
and because they are they basically
trying to say that we are okay with our
own kind raping our own kind
that's literally a core what they said
they said British crimes should be
perpetrated by British people is that
you should be should be it should be
normally is really
let's do with the the second to last the
pronounceable thing you just mentioned
the the most recent Co which is the
Charlie's place now online protection
Center yeah they looked at 2379
potential offenders called grooming
girls since 2008 and basically they
found that 26 percent of those
individuals were Asian yeah 38 percent
were white etc now of the Asians in 2012
that 415 were of the Asian there were
thirty five of which were which were
Pakistani so here because he's mentioned
Pakistanis Brian yes what he said is
actually factually incorrect yeah well
he said according to the most
authoritative body in this country that
analyzes these statistics is actually
factually incorrect and he's been
allowed to get away with it he said that
this is a particular problem for pack
Donnie's actually factually that's not
correct cuz only 35 of 415 Asians were
Pakistani five of them were from
Bangladesh which means to say that 10%
and this is what this is what people
have said about this 10% The Guardian I
said 10% of the Asians were Muslim so in
other words this is not a specific Asia
it's not specific Muslim problem as was
suggested as what suggest in the
beginning when they said it was a Muslim
issue now this is one point the second
point is really really important anyways
which is the the last thing he said he
said that this is not an issue okay
which relates to other races which is
completely false when you look at it
from an international perspective the
Polaris Project which is one of the
leading once again authorities in this
conducted a survey which using central
the Bureau of central statistics in
America's statistics found that 77% of
Americans being humanely being human
trafficked like the human trafficking
going on are people of color are people
of color so basically black people
people from Asia etc and the people that
are doing this the most are in fact
white people so human trafficking in
many ways is more severe than grooming
because it's literally selling slaves
for the purpose of sexual exploitation
yeah this is happening in the United
States of America
more so from white people to the people
of color then it is happening in the UK
hey so I I want to be talking about it
for a minute yeah yeah I want I want to
use that because this is what exactly
he's doing here yeah
you said him in America there's these
Caucasian men who while using colored
girls they send them for sex yeah yeah
okay so slavery bit okay okay
I'm gonna put Tony Robinson brain yeah
I'm here for this gonna be hard for me
to be in but and okay alright it's a
Christian country well the majority of
Americans according to the census
business yeah sometime Robinson I just
want a direct question yeah so you would
say Christian yeah okay they follow the
Bible the majority of them are they
Caucasian the majority of them is
exploitation happening yes that's a
Christian issue to me so yeah if you
take the same look that's the thing if
you take the same this is exactly what's
so now I want you guys to understand
this is the reason why so would I have a
right to go to Tommy and say look mate
you're a Christian now don't be a
Christian yet I want you this is your
problem right now yeah what are you
gonna do about how do you feel well
that's the point this is a false premise
here that just because there's a
correlation that there's a causation and
there's a difference between correlation
and causation for example if we did a
study on obese people yeah
obesity and a prayer and depression if
we did a study on obesity and depression
right yeah and we picked up a sample of
a hundred people and we said that we
want to find out if obesity leads to
depression we asked those individuals
are you depressed and some of them say
well the majority don't say yes that's a
correlation but we have no right to
judge that the reason for the depression
is you're busy because it could be that
it's depression that led to obesity
rather than be see the little depression
so correlations and causations are two
different things
you have to look holistically at the
situation and one more thing that I just
wanted to mention quickly was the NSPCC
has said that 90% because we talked
about human trafficking being a general
sexual exploitation problem but the
NSPCC I said relate and related in
relation to children that ninety percent
of children have been sexually abused at
one stage by but by adults and for the
most part these are not can't be a jiz
because there were there family members
so here we have layers of problems we
have exploitation which is one layer
general sexual exploitation which is a
problem in the West it's a problem in
the West and it's not something you can
scale up to Muslim communities or any
other communities you have a problem of
sexual as child exploitation in which
the NSPCC is reaching epidemic levels of
90% right and the majority of people
that are taking part of this are people
you know family members doing it to
their own children or to their own
nieces of their own wherever maybe this
is happening so 90% of these people are
in fact they can't be Muslim by virtue
of population because Muslims account
for 5% of the UK population so from
these perspectives it seems like these
narratives what they're intentionally
doing is they're trying to sabotage
statistical information in order to
derive some kind of false conclusion
about Muslim
depravity in ruga in relation to sexual
divorce or exploitation ya know to be to
be honest look the fact that there's
non-muslims doing this or non-asians you
need to bring an argument where you're
gonna say look you look everywhere there
are nobody for Asians and Muslim then we
will say you know what okay there is a
problem going on here but anyway this
watch it and then we're gonna come to
you've got something to say yeah but
listen let's watch it cuz it might have
been traced back as far as the late
1980s at-risk white English girls often
from broken homes and some as young as
nine years old were rude or groomed by
teenage Muslim boys called Romeo's and
even by groups of Muslim men who hung
around school gates the plan was to make
the girl feel important she was given
gifts and drugs but she was being
groomed to be a drug-addicted prostitute
then came the gang rapes the girls were
threatened with death if they tried to
flee it's not just sexual abuse
unspeakable levels of violence victims
being raped with knives big things being
raped with bottles victims having their
tongue nailed to tables these are
sometimes girls who have been picked up
from children's homes on a Friday are
being raped during the course of the
weekend by hundreds of men and then
returned with bleeding groins back to
the children's hands on a Monday morning
and they don't do anything about it at
all
Christine's goddaughter was preyed on by
the grooming gangs they pulled up by the
side of rink eyes they tried to get her
in the car they would talk if she were
come on come with us we'll take here
will take you there were you saying that
the authorities make it sound like
because the English girls follow the
parents fault it's your fault because
you haven't got control of your child if
you are a young English girl
particularly between the ages of nine
and fourteen and you find yourself
subject to the perversions of Muslim men
you effectively exist in a country where
the forces of law and order don't
existed they said Muslim way too many
times yes you know if it was such a
Muslim problem yet if you look at the
top five countries in which a rape is
just that the highest yeah the top five
countries
number one is the US yeah and they are
majority Christian country number two
South Africa
majority Christian country number three
Sweden
Wow it is the country we're going days
well number four behalf when you go
there number four is India Hindu country
mmm and number five UK which is atheist
/ Christian country not one of them are
majority Muslim country if this was such
an issue it would be just that that one
is on just destroys the whole argument
but if you if you look at the facts
no one credible has mentioned religion
don't have any credible research or
peer-reviewed journals that has claimed
we've backed up research that it is a
Muslim Islamic problem number one no
judge linked it to Islam you have no
victim has linked it to Islam no police
report has linked it to Islam so the
question arises where on earth is this
Muslim thing coming from apartment far
out good apart from the fire rock group
now if if they're saying no it is a
Muslim problem you have to now conclude
that the police are wrong the judicial
system is wrong the victims are wrong or
the policing system is wrong
so between them all aside yeah you can
say oh the whole system is wrong could
the victim the victim would have
communication oh wow these these guys
before they were doing other than
talking about this verses of the Quran
and they're saying this and you know
praying there to have a Quran oh yeah
yeah not if they had the Quran open they
would not be doing another thing to
equate it back Asians equals Muslims
then the whole of India Hindus therefore
become Muslim then because their agent
the majority of Asians in this country
are Ashley Indian and I'm not a the
majority but it's the vast maybe the
majority actually majority of Indians
are Hindu in this country exactly so
again this time grooming game yeah let's
not get sucked up in a media frenzy
because of the voice of the far rights
let's kind of okay
just kind of just put that to the side
and academically let's look at this
grooming gangs the term where what was
the history where is it from
yeah it's only come to our screens in
about 2003
what does that mean that I did
existed before 2003 it did exist yeah
but because there was no minority that
was that could be scapegoated it wasn't
kind of put into the headlines it wasn't
made into a separate category you could
say I mean you have look you can think
of it this way you have the umbrella of
sexual exploitation underneath the
umbrella you have different segments so
you have rape you have child abuse you
have it and sometimes obviously they
link trafficking Ajay
and a lot of times they would link with
each other and so what I think the
problem with statistics another problem
we talked about the causality
correlation problem but it's another
problem which is that when you make your
own category sometimes you can do so
with the intent of marginalizing a
certain community why don't we just talk
about these problems generically like
for example human trafficking why don't
we talk about rape generally that's not
going to be mentioned because there's no
minority to pin down on exactly the
grooming gangs thing any time you told
grooming gang or terrorist who do you
think of first immediately now you think
of Muslim and that's what the EDL has
been doing immediately linking Muslim
with grooming and Muslim with the word
terrorist yeah human trafficking is an
old term yeah prostitution pimping there
are old terms for example we were
talking about pimping yeah 11 Hungarians
have been caught trafficking and
exploiting 250 women yeah one Brazilian
has made about a hundred and fifty
thousand from prostitution in the UK but
like you said because this is a term
that's been there for quite a while
grooming gangs this term hasn't it's a
it's a relatively fresh terms when you
carry on yeah it's untainted so it has
now been planted on the Muslims and now
because of what's being shown to us
repetitively it's being drilled into her
subconscious now okay this Stephen
Lennon also known as Tommy Robinson
former leader of the English Defence
League was just a young boy in the town
of Luton when he learned a family member
had been victimized by a grooming gang
my cousin was great and she was found
naked running from the Muslim community
I stir he policemen help running from
the Muslim community so such a big words
that his Muslim community
millions are they in this console she
was running away from all the Muslims
the police were saying she's a drug
addict she was a drug addict because
they got hooked on drugs off to Bremen
and raped her some say grooming gangs
originated from a particular region of
Pakistan but others point out that the
Koran encourages Muslims to take enemy
women as sex slaves and that Muhammad
had sex with a nine year old wife for
example Robinson we don't have an issue
with him and we don't we don't see him
you know what why are you going after
these vile individuals these Pakistani
we don't have a problem with you going
after them I'm being honest with you if
you run me today and said look I'm gonna
go there you come I'll see you look time
and place yeah because the thing is my
issue is this you're going there and
making it seem a Muslim problem my issue
is that when you go to these terrorist
attacks happen you make it a Muslim
problem not you don't see it okay look
this terrorism done yes
terrorism done is done by the rights of
people from different backgrounds you
don't trying to say we don't have that
issue with you the issue is that you
take things out of context I mean let me
just address what he said here yes he
made a couple of allegations we said
that with with that I think the prophets
wire so now we meet men you made a video
so that we so that you can guys can
refer to that but just quickly on the
other issue the other issue of what the
right hand possesses which is referred
to in the Quran now the thing is you
have to understand that this is
referring to prisoners of war that
actually is completely dependent upon as
you've mentioned the social and
political context it does not apply in
today's world according to the consensus
of the scholars because now there is no
such thing as prisoners of war that
we're not in a state of war and this is
the reality of the situation so no one
can use this in example now having said
that once again as you correctly said
yeah you correctly said that basically
in America a so you could you could
argue because the majority are actually
Christian yeah I could I could pull out
30 numbers 31 18 and say look it's just
that go and go into the town and killed
take the woman as the young the young
girls as slaves and I can say look this
is linked to this so most Christians
would object to that and rightfully so
and rightfully so they say listen this
is no
why because actually I don't think
they're aspired by this the same thing
would apply with us I bet you they don't
eat they don't even know this verse I
bet you not a single will say you know
what I did what I did why because I
challenge you look I'm being very
clear-cut here they would not same way
with these guys I'm sorry yeah looking
at their lifestyle and what they're
doing
you were far from like I'm sorry you are
far from what islam teaches and this is
why you do it why do you think another
question
why do you think this minute these men
are doing what they're doing why why
because it was used that easy target to
me it seems they're like whichever wants
an easy target yeah to the issue here
that many times and it's easy they're
looking for easy target do you get it
and if that easy target is a black girls
for black yours if it's Muslim girls
they're gonna go for Muslim girls if
it's wag yours which that what they're
doing the most that you can say you know
what these guys are racist do you see
I'm Chauncey you know what's interesting
as well as that this news report is kind
of contradicting itself first is talking
about how these people are addicted to
drugs and these these kind of things and
then didn't orally addicted to drugs but
they actually supply it for the people
that they grew yeah but at the same time
they meant to represent an Orthodox
strand of Islam or an extremist form of
Islam even you know so having said that
it doesn't make any sense because
there's no interpretation not even the
extremists abhorrent Isis interpretation
of Islam that allows for example and the
consumption of intoxicants so here we
don't see what would you want us to
believe there's no correlation if there
is no is no causation is somebody just
trying to connect it yeah that you have
to try hard to connect and it's all
based on emotions v it doesn't show it
scripture doesn't show it there yeah so
now you guys set numbers now if we look
at Romania yeah
Romania is 98 percent Christian yeah
there was an issue of a Romanian
pedophile who groomed 10 kids yeah now
is that now a Christian problem why was
there no mention of the word Christian
in in any of the articles the news
coverage now if you look at say Poland
94% Christian yeah country same issue
happened no mention of the word
Christian you know Eve even in Hungary
yeah there's a grooming gang who
exploited hundreds of women yeah
hundreds of women for six years
hundreds of women for 60 years where do
we get this one yeah now they are over
fifty percent of the country's Christian
yeah no majority Christian nation are
you going to link that to Christianity
when jimmy savile yeah jimmy savile was
he had a Roman Catholic upbringing his
religion isn't getting mentioned the
texts are being scrutinized versus
aren't being taken out of context you
take someone like Richard Huckle who's a
practicing Christian from Kent and he
went to Malaysia abusing kids his
religion that was the purpose of his
visit his religion wasn't brought up
Bible texts weren't taken and the
Christian community weren't told to
apologise for these acts yet these are
majority Romania Poland Hungary in fact
the thing is the danger is when you
monopolize to a particular color or
religion yeah what you are now doing is
you're painting their perpetrators of a
certain color and a faith which gives
free pass to the others
that's why initially the police failed
to do so the West because of its power
structures innocently being on top in
the media and all those kind of things
he says that you're always gonna have in
the West the bad guy so as you mentioned
correctly before you had the black guys
the Jews well we're in Europe actually
there's a Jewish problem in your yeah
then you have and would you cool it then
you have Russia these Russians just
because all of these individuals had
their turn
laughing the Koreans I don't think but
if these people are more responsible and
like you said if they are just and they
go to Christian perpetrators they go to
white black perpetrators they will be
more just and if you just you can tackle
this issue head-on now we're not saying
that Asians or Muslims they are exempt
from this we're saying look if it is an
issue go for it but whatever this issue
is arising deal with it holistically
don't just deal with fringe elements if
it's happening with MPs yeah and it's
been covered up deal with it if it
things are happening online deal with it
we're asking Tony Robinson look we're
not even asking you to find us we will
come to you no problem we've we've tips
before say again here look you're going
to people who kind of speak English
properly exit
we're Saints you look why don't you come
and talk to one of us all the arguments
the profit margin higher at nine these
sex aids whatever you claim no problem
why don't you come and talk to us
because you know it will be intellectual
burial because you know intellectual
you'll be buried because this is what
you thrive on put in terror in the
people's hearts and you make money of
that
oh yeah it's already wrote a book
recently ya know it's crazy I'm sorry is
that Hitler writing a book on the Old
Testament yeah he's just not I don't
want to humiliate anyone here but no the
point is like someone who might not even
have formal GCSE qualifications I mean I
don't even know if he's got a C grade in
math in English someone like that
writing an academic piece on Islam a
religion which he has no idea about in a
language which he has not it does not
rise on naming so guys I hope you guys
have benefited that's about it really do
share this with your friends or family
and non Muslim as well that's it